hi Carmichael welcome to another edition
of ask Evan in today's video I'm going
to answer questions from one of my
readers Jason who's asking me about what
is the most effective internet marketing
strategy so Roden hi it's Jason I'm new
around and it seems this is the place
that has a lot to offer that I surely
love I just want to seek advice what be
the most effective internet strategy
that people can use to do well with
online businesses have you ever tried a
valuable technique hope to hear from you
thanks regardless of Jason so Jason I've
tried a lot of different things and what
I find works the best it might be the
most boring but it's search engine
optimization when somebody finds you
through a search engine I found that to
be the most effective strategy and I do
a lot of social media stuff and that's
kind of all the hype of the YouTube
channel and Twitter and Facebook and
everything else but I find that I get
the most customers and the most money
from doing search engine optimization
and what you find is when somebody finds
you from a search engine they're looking
for a solution to a problem that they
have right we think about when you're
searching for something you're trying to
find a best solution to a specific issue
that you have with your business or your
personal life so they're more committed
to look for a solution and want to
potentially box if you have a product
that you're selling that's the best type
of customer you can have when somebody
finds you through a social media channel
they're looking to be entertained
they're looking to you know browse
around different sites they're probably
not gonna buy from you as much so the
conversion rates from social media is
typically super low compared to search
engine optimization so if I were you if
I was only going to focus on one
strategy a look at how can I get my
website optimized for key phrases that I
think will drive targeted
to my business so I hope that helps if
you guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up below I'd also love to hear
what your experiences are what you feel
are the best ways to market yourself
online if you want to leave a comment
below this video and stay tuned for next
episode
you